زعيم الحوثيين اليمني يتعهد بمزيد من
التصعيد إذا لم تتوقف الحرب على غزة،
ويزعمون أن هجماتهم على السفن في البحر الأحمر
هي تضامن مع
الشعب الفلسطيني هناك،
ولم تردعهم الغارات الأمريكية والبريطانية، ومن المؤكد أن الحوثيين
لديهم خبرة في
الصمود في وجه هذه الضربات  تحت سنوات من
الحملة السعودية ضدهم هشام
العيسي يعرف هذه المجموعة جيدا لأنه
في عام 2017 اعتقلوه في العاصمة
صنعاء واحتجزوه لعدة أشهر وهو
ينضم إلينا الآن مع بعض التحليلات من
واشنطن العاصمة أه مرحبا بكم في البرنامج
قبل أن أسألكم  بخصوص
مواجهتك معهم، أخبرنا
قليلاً عن من هم المثيرون للاهتمام
ولماذا بعد أسابيع من الهجمات
ضد مواقعهم العسكرية،
لم
يردعهم ذلك، شكرًا لك أه حسنًا لنبدأ
بالحوثيين  المجموعة المتمردة
الدولة البوليسية الثيوقراطية وكانوا يأملون في الحصول على
هذه الفرصة لهذه المواجهة
مع الولايات المتحدة منذ فترة منذ ما يقرب من
30 عامًا وكانوا يدعون أنهم
كانوا يقاتلون
القوى الإمبريالية الاستعمارية في المنطقة، لذلك هذا في
الواقع  زودتهم
بفرصة ذهبية ولم تكن الضربات
فعالة ضدهم، وإذا كان هناك أي شيء
يغذي غضبهم فهو في
الواقع يحفزهم ولكن أيضًا
لأن أسلحتهم منتشرة للغاية
عبر السلاسل الجبلية وهم
ينتجون أيضًا بعضًا من تلك
الصواريخ محليًا نعم مكوناتها  تأتي
المكونات من إيران، وتأتي المكونات من
مكان آخر، ويأتي المدربون من
الحسبة، ولكن مرة أخرى لديهم
القدرة المحلية على إعادة بناء تلك الأكوام وإعادة تخزينها،
لذلك نحن عالقون في حلقة من
التوتر يمكن أن تستمر لفترة طويلة جدًا
من الزمن و  طبعا بعد
الضربات الأمريكية على أه العراق وسوريا وعلى
الميليشيات المدعومة من إيران هناك خلال
نهاية الأسبوع أه تعلم أن الجميع يتحدث
عن مدى أه السيطرة والتوجيه الذي
تعطيه إيران لوكلائها في ما
يسمى بمحور المقاومة لذلك من
الخاص  تجربة ما هي النسبية أه كما
تعلم تبعيات هؤلاء الوكلاء
على
إيران أعتقد أن هناك القليل من
المبالغة لأن الكثير من الناس
يزعمون أن إيران لديها أه سيطرة قوية جدًا
على الحوثيين في حين أن الحوثيين في الواقع
لديهم مقود أطول للحوثيين نعم هم  "
إنهم مدعومون جيدًا من قبل الإيرانيين، وهم
يدينون بصعودهم للإيرانيين ولكن
الأمر هو أن لديهم أيضًا
عقليتهم الخاصة ويتبعون نفس
قواعد اللعبة، إنهم منظمون
تحت نفس محور المقاومة ولكن
لديهم أهدافهم الخاصة".
ولهذا السبب
يتوسعون بشكل أساسي داخل اليمن،
ويتبنون رواياتهم الخاصة،
ولديهم لهجة دينية خاصة بهم،
كما أن لديهم سيطرتهم الخاصة على
مراكز التحكم المنتشرة
في جميع أنحاء اليمن، مما يجعل الأمر
صعبًا للغاية.  بالنسبة للولايات المتحدة والمملكة المتحدة
لإضعاف
جيشهما محليًا نوعًا ما، ولكن مرة أخرى إيران على الرغم من
دعمها للحوثيين، إلا أنها لا
تسيطر بشكل كامل على هوديس